all right let's tears are that I want to
talk to you about small software like a
lot of people in this room that grew up
being really engaged with computers and
being someone whose engagement computers
I was incredibly socially popular and
and in good with the ladies but
excellent this this time about 1988 was
a great time to be this kid because of
course we were that generation who in
the first generation to get home
computers and I grew up very much an
apple household now the Apple on the
left and not the Apple on the right the
apple before somebody said he suck all
the caller ID of it and freeze it into
ice this is it a different apple from
the one that we experience today and it
was an apple that was drinking as much
by this guy on the left is it was by
this time the right is invading that is
feel like it's in great crowd most
people seem to was the outcomes is
terrible and really specifically I want
to talk about one thing that bill
atkinson was responsible for the type of
car yea rather round of applause you can
see how far apples interface this
involves head McCarver right back where
we started in with the iPad a hypercar
was a program that people would use to
make small software things like a
program to track basketball scores for
their local basketball team or maybe a
calculator to help them out with very
simple calculations were a program that
would help them in their research and of
course people were also using HyperCard
to make artwork this is one of my
favorite ones called his monks had max
by Brian Thomas it was this kind of
linear nonlinear storytelling for net
which let you explore the strange world
of science and mathematics and ryan
Thomas has this really great quote which
I which I dug up when I was putting
together this top and I know that you
guys could read so I'm not going to redo
quote but but the if I was going to pick
a phrase that was
come up from this quote is this phrase
of code Punk this idea making software
without the weight of profit behind it
and that has a lot of to do with what I
want to talk about with small software
so I think small software and soft
artist is a program called the color
economy which is a simulated economy in
which pixels trade color red green and
blue it's an agent based system
mentioned get us talking about economies
and sometimes these things are a little
more practical this next one is is a
visualization of all the planets that
Kepler project discovered and this is
something that i made in about four or
five hours with no other intention other
than to allow myself to learn a little
bit more about this system I wasn't
trying to start a company or build an
app I was just trying to build so I set
very small consist hopper and this very
small piece of software let me address
that system of information in the way
that couldn't be done with a big piece
of software because that piece of data
has character all its own these are
planets they're not things that can be
normally visualized another example a
much bigger example i built an algorithm
in a software tool which allowed the
architect in place did nearly three
thousand names that are on the 911
memorial in manhattan but here is a very
specific piece of data that has a very
specific contacts and big software
cannot attack a problem like this it
cannot solve a problem like this only
small software can and work at the New
York Times where I'm the data artists
and residence and what we've learned at
New York Times assistive we can build
these bespoke these custom tailored
systems that can uniquely engage with
specific systems rather than thinking
about giant the software they can engage
with every system we think about small
pieces which can engage in small system
what are the nice things that allow
small software is that small software
can become nik software big supper
cannot become small software this law
software can become big software so we
started this project in the times of
last year called cascade and what
cascade is is it's a tool which lets us
look at how times
is shared through social media no x
content is has its own character there
there's something about x time that
means that people are sharing it quite a
lot so a single event like this event
that we see right here can grow into
many events i'm going to show you three
views in the same system this is all
from a story that was published last
year shortly after Steve Jobs death here
is a side view what we call of an event
cascade which is all resulting this is
about 16 hours of traffic from from one
particular event that cascaded into
another event here's another view of it
we call radar view which allows us to
see these threads of conversation which
carry through the system and this is a
real-time tool it's an exploratory tool
and and these stills don't really do it
justice neither does this next one which
is that which is the video of this
system because in real life this runs on
a 5 screen video wall and it's
controlled by an iphone and people who
go through it and explore the nearly
7,000 positive content that the time is
publishes every month and how people are
engaging with those pieces so this idea
of small software i think is really
important and and big software it
doesn't accomplish the the ability to
examine the character of these problems
that are really important to engage with
thank
you